if you have a problem with what laura
ingraham did to mr. bass excuse me I'm
not finished mister random - another day
another showdown on the view I think
that's why people like the show it took
less than ten minutes for things to get
heated on Tuesday's episode of the
daytime talk show and it all ended with
Whoopi Goldberg
lecturing Meghan McCain about respect
it's the view it is the view you know
what let me tell you something about the
view this show has always had the
ability to have different points of view
which we respect around the table let's
rewind when the ladies got on the topic
of a military officer asked to testify
about president Donald Trump's Ukraine
call things quickly turned into a
shouting match between Meghan and joy
behar just because somebody serve does
not it's so facto makes them above
reproach
no man where I come from it's guy for me
yeah you get a pass for because
automatically you get if you are putting
your life on the line country and
veterans and people by the way I'm just
got a pass from me that's when Whoopie
stepped in to cool things down everybody
just take a breath yes now it's it's
peep hold on let me just finish what I'm
saying so that I can just say everybody
has something to say at the table we
really do want to hear from everybody
but we're starting to do that thing
right and so I'm that since this thing
it means you're talking over each other
well it's a it's the view Whoopi stayed
calm
pointing out that she just wanted to
make sure everyone's voice was heard
when I'm saying to you hold up because
we're not hearing each other I'm not
trying to cut you off I'm trying to get
you hurt I don't think that's what are
you doing right now
we'll be back it was kind of an
unexpected moment from the moderator who
told et just this month she really
doesn't think twice about the conflict
on her show I don't think about it
my
J consists of waking up happy to be
above ground and anything that I get
after that is sugar candy as for Megan
she told the tea at the start of the new
season she's never one to back down and
I think that's why people like the show
is they know it's not scripted and they
know it's not we're not being phony and
I'm not trying to placate to an audience
I always say we're like the only show
that will talk about like JLo and a-rod
and North Korea in the same show and I
think that's important
[Music]